how do you f how do you guys think like
trash tv fits into everything would you
call trash t like which what rating
would you give like kitchen nightmares
or something like that or uh 90 day
fiance i think it just depends because
like people it depends if you grew up on
it or not all right like like during
like you know were you were you
surrounded
ramsay yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm in i'm
invested in that character i like it i
know that most of it especially in
kitchen nightmares like all faked
but also that's the thing
it depends on like if you were like
raised in a family where like it was
like a family event to be like oh it's
wednesday night let's watch kitchen
nightmares you know that kind of thing
right like i didn't grow up in a family
like that so like to me like i didn't
grow up with trash tv at all so we never
watched it together
yeah oh okay okay so like because like
the first time i knew about like kitchen
nightmare was like through like youtube
clips like like any tlc show right i was
like what the [ __ ] is this yeah just
because like i knew kitchen nightmares
uh because that was like literally when
i first saw gordon ramsay as well it was
it was the british kitchen nightmares as
well which was like you compare british
kitchen nightmares to american kitchen
nightmares and it's like [ __ ] night
and day
like not only the editing but just how
like toned down gordon ramsay is as well
tied down in the british one yeah he's
toned down he's like he it it's it's
different right because it feels like in
the american one it feels like they
actually get like a formula huh
it is a formula but you know
it feels like they get like the worst of
the worst [ __ ] chefs and restaurant
like actual clowns yeah uh to to like
present their dish to gordon ramsay and
it's almost like cartoonish in a way and
yeah you look at the british one and it
feels like that it's just like like
chefs who actually give a [ __ ] about
their food who actually just like you
just need some advice who needs some
advice a lot of the times gordon ramsay
is like giving them like genuine advice
and maybe they're too headstrong or
maybe they're too like you know prideful
to really listen to his advice
whereas you know in america it actually
feels more like this is
this is not even reality tv anymore this
looks so cartoony and feels so over the
top that you just don't even take it i
feel that way about like 99 of american
trash tv no you know which one the one i
hate the most i i hate it because i i
used to also watch it a lot the [ __ ]
porn stars oh yeah what's that one you
you know it it's the one you know it's
it's the it's the one it's set in vegas
right it's like the one with the bald
guy and someone comes in he's like i've
got a i've got this thing worth 20
million dollars and he's like i'll give
you 10 bucks for it
yeah oh oh i thought you said porn stars
like we're british
i was like what is this reality tv show
how stars and there's also hardcore porn
as well which is the other one there was
like a spin-off to that there was like a
british version of it as well which is
just like what was it called porn in it
car boot sailors or something like that
right yeah like it was like
that show is just because it's so forgot
it's so obviously fake but also at the
same time you're like
it's just cool just seeing weird [ __ ]
brought in i've i've driven past uh the
porn star's place but it's invading i
don't even
and it's just like because it's in the
most ghetto part of vegas it's so scary
and then like you know there'll be this
this guy comes in he'll be like i have
this uh mummified corpse that's been
sitting in my grandma's attic in nevada
yeah right he's like oh you know i know
an expert i'm going to bring him down
and ten seconds later the expert's there
he's like well it is a mummified corpse
uh it's worth about fifty thousand
dollars and then he goes oh it's i'll
give you 20 bucks for it what are you
going to do with the mummy cooks we're
the whole formula [ __ ] and then they
just walk out angrily it's like you're
missing out on a great deal man
yeah i mean what i did what i didn't
understand about porn stars it's like
when they started starting i guess
introducing story lines like like or
play
yeah they would be like b-line plots
with their family that would get
resolved in an episode like it's a
episode of like happy days or something
like that storage wars as well yeah oh
my god i remember the story that was so
big in the uk the american one played in
the on uk television so [ __ ] great
yeah it was so popular it was ridiculous
yeah i just i just like yeah thinking
back on i used to yeah that was the one
actually trash tv that came on
australian tv all the time and my dad
was obsessed i just loved it because
they were just they would literally be a
pile of [ __ ] in this room and these guys
were like so about 50 bucks sell out for
20 bucks like where are you going to
sell this to there's like a used bed
she's like there's five bucks right
there it's like no it's not you're not
selling whatever what if so it's like
all connected like the trash tv universe
where like they think they crash tv like
like in storage wars they like they take
all the [ __ ] and then they go to the
porn stars
because it's like half the time you know
of course there'll be these ones these
fake ones will be like this guy has a
a lot full of perfect rarity charizards
yeah perfect grain it's like well
obviously we can sell those but other
times there's just lots or something
where it's just all [ __ ] and you're like
even if you could make a profit selling
this surely the amount of time to get
rid of all of this [ __ ] and sell it it's
just not worth it no like yeah you could
sell this the pack of double a batteries
for 10 bucks if you really wanted to but
why would you like where are you going
to sell this to
are you shipping it surely that has to
be taken into account
this is this is the only country where i
see that working you know where you
where you can actually sell the stuff
and people will buy it they do have
storage lots in japan i don't think they
sell them do they when they
when they no i don't appreciate they
actually use storage for storage
purposes but the store is a lot i think
when if somebody like doesn't collect it
i think they just get rid of all the
stuff yeah they just don't think they
sell them to the public which would be
shame because we the japan storage wars
version
that would be all these wars dude that
would be epic
tonight directions you can get a great
deal
like what kind what like i think i know
more american reality tv shows and i
know british reality tv shows i can't
think of like we have uh we have a naked
attraction you know i'm naked attraction
i love that when i went back to the uk i
really like that was on that was still
on tv it was still airing my channel
sure you know the ones that actually the
one i the what there's a real tv show
where you feel bad watching you know but
even if it's i don't know how much it's
fake like you know the debt collectors
won oh yeah that's the one where i'm
always like even if this is fake should
we really be which one's that story
lines it's like uh there's a bunch in
the uk we [ __ ] love debt collecting
shows in the uk for some reason
we love watching debt collectors as long
as we're not on the budget yeah
so what's the premise
just go and collect debt it's just like
it's just like jim is is
the bank fifty thousand dollars and so
jeremy over here is going to go over to
his house and collect this let's see
what happens but in the in the british
one it's just like some guy goes to
their house hey we'll come here to get
the stuff and then like [ __ ] off no
you're [ __ ] getting my thing [ __ ]
right off and they're like they've got a
high high magistrates caught notice to
collect the stuff if they don't they'll
start collecting things off the property
and then they and then the police turn
up and then it's just it's just [ __ ]
because it's like oh these poor people
who've had a horrible circumstance and
then we're just we're just shoving
cameras in their face while their
apartment's being ransacked and so yeah
they're selling the stuff off yeah
they're just like how do you feel
yeah they should have paid their debts
but wouldn't everyone pay their debts if
they could
but is it called can't pay we'll take it
away that's it what a stupid car pay day
i have never heard of that name watch it
it's on channel five day okay i don't i
don't watch show i'm gonna send you
later i don't think i've ever watched a
single program i guarantee if you watch
one you'll get hooked it's it's horrible
tv
it's just the trash
channel
it's it's so addictive watching this
stuff like to me like i don't know why
you just can't help yourself to me like
channel four is where a lot of like the
trash tv goes yeah um even though i
can't like think of it no channel four
is good stuff too though yeah but
channel 4 which i think channel 4 is
like actually one of like the best the
best channel was it it has like the
widest range and it seems like to be the
most experimental as well bbc is just
like very standard here's your like
[ __ ] doctor who's the voice
here's the voice itv is just like here's
his x factor once again that's a reality
tv show actually yeah that's right yeah
i completely forgot that's just like
reality tv show just like times 100
though right but no one cares about
singing reality like does it is still
going huh does anyone is still happening
oh yeah i'm sure i'm pretty sure does
anyone give a [ __ ] love island as well
love island that's is that is that itv i
feel like that's itv
yeah so you've got like i i feel like
that's really popular in america as well
the british one yeah it's really popular
yeah it is oh the great british break
off as well i completely forgot about it
it can't be called bake off in the us
really they can't uh one of the the us
brands has um the trademark
uh one of them has the the trademark to
take off so they it's called something
else in america and they've had to look
off
something and they've had to actually in
the net i think on netflix they've had
to like
animate over certain parts of the show
like the trophy they've had to like they
they did a they did see cgi where they
trade that changed what the trophy said
wow oh it's called the great american
baking show yeah the great american
baking show yeah because they didn't
have the rights for the wood bake off oh
wow because for some reason a company
owns the right for the wood bake off
which is weird um so yeah they changed
it so that is popular in the us but it's
called technically something different
the baking show
the great british baking shirt just just
doesn't roll off the tongue's word
i know right i know does australia have
any reality tv shows uh i mean we got
like australian idol and like the voice
australia and like all that [ __ ] um how
did the voice get popular i like like
when
at which point in time did we decide we
need more than one singing reality tv
show when was x factor just not enough i
think it's because like shows like x
factor and like american idol were like
uh a lot of the times there was like
contestion of like are they like judging
them on their actual singing or are they
judging them on their performance so
people are like we want to know if they
can actually sing and looks don't matter
you know like that whole like [ __ ]
like you know
like inclusive things how they treat you
the audience is idiots and feed you
these garbage story lines yeah
i also just get confused about like the
judges on a lot of them like x factor
has like or brilliant has like [ __ ]
ruined so many [ __ ] songs for me just
because of like they use it at like the
emotional the emotional point like if i
hear like you raise me up one more
[ __ ] time it's always you raise me up
right yeah like golden buzzer
it's like the x factor wait did they
didn't didn't win susan boyle right yeah
there's season ball went no she came
second right
did susan boyle win
so it's like that that is like the peak
of how tv manipulates yeah that us to
just wanna you know they'll give you an
underdog and they've got a sad story oh
no i've never had a boyfriend oh oh no
you know and
the show doesn't give a [ __ ] they
haven't had a boyfriend but they're like
look audience care care about this care
about this they do all the time uh as
well with like military stuff yeah yeah
they're like you know they'll you know
they'll be someone who wants to compete
who maybe like served in uh afghanistan
or something and instead of just being
like hey this is the town it's like no
you're the guy who went to afghanistan
your whole identity is about going to
afghanistan and you're doing this for
your troops back in afghanistan because
they're one last wishes to see you
perform that's what they do that's what
they do yeah i was watching a thing with
um chris in the hotel room
and it was a british scott britt's got
talent person who um was performing
magic and they they served in the
military yeah yeah yeah and it was just
insulting how they almost just shoved it
down your throat it's like this is the
guy's only
re reality as a human being is that he's
served in a war and it's like god can we
not just be people do we have to just
like ha do do we do we have to just
shove down these things
how about you follow the name of your
show and just be like do you have a
talent yes or no this is not about this
but how is your story compelling yeah so
on this magic show this guy is doing
these tricks and stuff and you know not
to to not to minimize it but it was
almost beat for be predictable and
there's just
a nice
so this is one trick where he was doing
and he was like oh look at the the clock
and and tell me the time and so right
before the the point of this trick goes
i was like chris to chris i was like
because chris is watching it yeah and i
was like i bet it's the time where one
of his friends died or something in the
war yeah no [ __ ] you're not two seconds
later he's like that's the time when my
friend passed oh my god and it's like
okay don't get me wrong i want to say
that
that is obviously horrific and stuff but
yeah the fact that they're using this as
like bait for almost like even trivial
trivialized because if it doesn't feel
real it does like the impact is gone
because it feels so manufactured it's
just like they might as well just put up
a cue card to be like now crying yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like
again i want to make sure i'm not
diminishing it or like yeah i'm trying
to minimize it minimize it or make it
seem like it's not on the guy it's on
the editor
it's on the producers yeah
probably heard this story or something
like yo play that up play that
people want to [ __ ] cry yeah because
like because like it's been proven
plenty of times that the
the auditions that we see televise in
front of a live audience isn't actually
like the first audition they go through
like several stages with the producers i
guarantee he was doing that magic trick
and like one of the producers like just
like
heavily suggested yo you should you
should uh speculation by the way
speculation speculation but uh i like in
my mind i'm just like
i feel like one of one of the producers
just went you know i feel like you
should uh
kind of like try to integrate that
storyline into your magic trick somehow
you know it's definitely kind of stuff
that those you know producers are
would do like we've seen you know if you
have a look at the people who've
released the contracts and stuff they're
pretty predatory contracts oh yeah yeah
yeah i think a lot of the time i think i
covered which one it was either one of
these shows one of the british ones is
like
they by signing the contract
they owned everything that you would
make that you would self-publish online
or something i think it was american
idol one of them was like yeah
if you went to even audition and you
posted content online if they wanted to
they could turn around and be like hey
that's us we that's us bro yeah that's
just [ __ ] yeah
yeah i think it might have been i think
it was like because i saw the youtube
video about it yeah um also susan when
she lost out to like diversity that's
right the people who did i remember i
remember this
big like because i think everyone at the
time
i remember when this was happening when
i was younger and everyone was like oh
susan ball's going to win so like yeah
it was a big effort to like make it so
that she didn't win or yeah
opinion this is when people gave a [ __ ]
about reality tv yeah now now life is
the reality tv we don't need this [ __ ]
we are like just log on to our [ __ ]
twitter and uh you you get to see
reality tv where's where's susan boyle
now hopefully doing well for herself but
no one's talking about her i i would
like to go on the go back to the times
when we could just [ __ ] on reality tv
and that that just have like zero effect
in our lives yeah that's that's the good
old days for me